we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 why don't we go next to our caller
from the three one four area code who's
calling today from three one four hi
David my name's Josh I'm from st. Louis
hey Josh what's going on hey mo longtime
listener first-time caller
and I actually became more politically
aware just like a few years ago in 2016
election and I was very more
conservative on a lot of stuff because
my family was conservative but once I
actually started reading and learning
more I kind of cross that line and I
started to become more liberal and then
just more progressive interesting so
yeah and so anyway um well Josh before
you glad I mean I'm curious was there
any particular issue where you realized
wow what the right is selling on this
issue is just totally wrong and this and
it was like a big catalyst for getting
you to revise your political beliefs
well one of the things was I never
really realized the hypocrisy I just
kind of like I was raised by my
grandparents and they're very pretty
conservative and I just kind of took
what they said you know at face value
and I'm like okay these are morals and
then my household was also very
religious growing up and so I just like
okay took this and it was really the I
guess I realized the hypocrisy at the
pro-life pro-choice mmm
saying because my grandfather is very
he's anti-big government and then I
heard an argument from years ago I think
on The Young Turks it was you know hey
like having the government come in and
tell you hey you want to you want to
control what a woman does that's big
government like okay that is and I took
it to my grandpa and then he was kind of
hypocritical on and I realized okay and
I started noticing all the trends of
hypocrisy interesting they're not
principled in their ideology got it got
it got it
interesting yeah so my question to you
is you know you kind of dedicate you
know your career is you know political
commentary like you're in it like all
the time
and so you know me I find myself getting
very fatigued you know it's hard just
kind of talking to people constantly
about it and then it's just like they my
my issue is that you know I'm around so
many people that are more right-wing and
then so so much my energy just gets
drained you know like you someone like
you like how do you you know how do you
find the energy to just keep doing it
pushing on and on you know just being
you know
so deep into it well listen I mean
number one I would suggest finding some
left-wing people to be around I don't
know and you know st. Louis is a big
enough city that there are probably like
drinking liberally or some local
Democrats group or something like I
would definitely try to spend time
around people where you don't even it's
not to talk politics it's not to talk
left-wing politics necessarily but it's
just to know that you're around people
who are like you in terms of ideology
because it is fatiguing to constantly be
around people that you know
fundamentally have a worldview and and
even in some cases like a moral code
that seems so antithetical to what you
believe so in my in my like personal
life there's very few conservative
people around me that's the reality and
I think that that's a really good thing
and I basically don't talk about
politics outside of the show so my
strategy is on the weekends as much as
possible I stay off social media and
don't do any tweeting or thinking about
politics to the extent that I can in my
sort of like day to day life I mostly
around people who more or less share my
ideology and I don't talk about politics
with them I'm just around people who
share my values and ideology and those
are the two things that I would suggest
you try to do and I think in st. Louis
it's more than possible boy all right
great to hear from you appreciate the
phone call let's take a quick break but
don't hang up if you're holding because
I will get back to the phones which are
jammed jam-packed a quick break back
after this